there's a tragic story coming out of
Texas a mass shooting and leftist
researchers in the corporate press are
running with this story that they've
discovered the profile of this
individual and lo this Mexican man is
actually a white supremacist now the
thing is it seems like researchers have
dug through this profile it does not
seem to be real this person was posting
weird things in the past couple of weeks
to no followers and to no one but of
course the media is going to run with it
in this there are on this profile there
are posts about Libs of tick tock and I
believe it's four clips from this show
from one particular episode that was
enough for them to come out and yeah now
Tim pool is trending and claim that this
individual was a fan of this show yeah
I'm gonna come out outright and just be
like you're Liars that's not the case
you don't get to say someone posted a
clip one time in your family because by
that metric Media Matters is our biggest
fan shout out to Media Matters for being
huge fans